[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo américa de france24 daniela
brandon ya está con nosotros en el
estudio daniela vamos a hablar de what's
it porque no solo abrió la semana con
fuertes pérdidas sino que el fenómeno
viene de antes si raúl pues el lunes o
un índice como el nasdaq que es el que
aglutina a las tecnológicas perdió casi
un 5% veremos cómo se comporta hoy y eso
trae a la memoria los peores momentos de
la pandemia cuando en un principio las
bolsas caían con fuerza en eeuu el
principal índice de dow jones ha caído
16 por ciento en lo que va del año hasta
el lunes el standard and poor's de las
500 empresas más valiosas ha borrado
casi un 22 por ciento de valor el nasdaq
ha perdido una tercera parte también de
su valor y todo esto entonces deja atrás
una espectacular racha que tuvieron
durante la pandemia después de ese
desplome inicial del que hablaba daniela
y qué significa esto digamos bueno la
noticia de ayer en la bolsa de nueva
york- más que la caída misma de los
índices fue que el standard and poor's
quizás el más representativo del mercado
en un nivel considerado como bajista
también se le conoce en wall street como
bear market porque los osos hibernan y
entran como en una serie de pausa cuando
hay un mercado alcista se le llama world
market que representa a un toro como lo
vemos en las imágenes y como hacen en
wall street cissé y como están words 7
mercado alcista como siempre quieren que
pase pues el principal enemigo de las
acciones son las tasas de interés altas
y ahora se suma la inflación la guerra
en ucrania la desaceleración de la
economía china y ahora en lo que hacen
los inversionistas es que se deshacen de
lo que tienen en activos de alto riesgo
como lo son las acciones o las cripto
monedas y llevan su dinero a lugares más
seguros como los cetes o los bonos del
tesoro también el dólar oro y otros
commodities ahora la fed debe mover con
pinzas esos intereses porque tienden a
ralentizar la economía si son altos y
muchos temen que incluso se pueda llegar
a una recesión
danny con todo esto le pregunto cómo
amaneció entonces el resto del mercado
bueno se están recuperando algunas de
las bolsas vemos el inicio de wall
street que abrió hace pocos minutos esta
esta el dow jones o industriales
subiendo un 0 10% de todas maneras muy
poquito y hoy veremos cómo se comportan
en el resto de la jornada las acciones
siguen esta misma tendencia en el mundo
en asia corea del sur retrocedió a
niveles de hace 19 meses europa opera
también a la baja con leves cambios y
todos esperando qué va a pasar con la
reserva federal y también la gente dirá
del salvador qué va a pasar con nuestra
economía y qué va a pasar con el bitcoin
que está pasando por un mal momento y
recordemos también como lo hemos venido
hablando equipo es el sabor y metió
muchísimo dinero en estaba escrito
moneda claro y porque hay temor porque
el script o monedas son un activo de
alto riesgo y ahora pues los
inversionistas están bastante cautelosos
como lo venimos diciendo la cripta
divisa más conocida está ya por debajo
de los 23 mil dólares cuando hace menos
de un año había tocado un récord de 68
mil dólares tres veces más de lo que
cuesta hoy ahora qué pasa en el salvador
se pregunta usted me preguntarán pues el
ministro de hacienda alejandro celaya
dice que el riesgo fiscal por la
implementación del activo digital como
moneda de pago junto al dólar
estadounidense
extremadamente mínimo y que no ha tenido
pérdidas hasta el momento porque no ha
vendido las monedas pero qué pasaría si
las vendiera saque la calculadora raúl
lo invito yo la tengo y el salvador
tiene dos mil trescientos un bitcoins
los compro entre septiembre de 2021 y
mayo de 2022 cuando costaban entre
30.000 más bueno solita mil 758 mil
dólares hoy el precio está muy por
debajo 23 mil dólares así que si los
vendiera hoy tendría unos 53 millones de
dólares eso qué quiere decir 18 millones
menos de lo que invirtió o entre 18 y 80
millones menos de lo que invirtió de
todas maneras y los vendiera hoy
perdería plan está claro hay le toque
esperar pero pues ahora adiós si sube o
si baja es era distal como que es el
riesgo
danny y amazon va a entregar pedidos con
drones a finales de año pues después de
una década de estudios el sistema
comenzará a probarse en lo que ford esto
es en california una pequeña ciudad de
unos tres mil habitantes el gigante del
comercio electrónico dice que ya tiene
la tecnología solamente le falta el
visto bueno de la administración federal
de aviación para que sus productos
caigan del cielo directamente a las
casas de los compradores pero amazon no
es el único su competidor walmart ha
estado probando desde el año pasado esta
clase de envíos en varios estados y
promete llegar a unos 4 millones de
hogares a un costo de menos de 4 dólares
y con capacidad de unas 10 libras por
envío raúl ya nos tiene como cifra el
día para finalizar esta economía de la
mañana en directo américa bueno una
cifra que les va a gustar a los
brasileños miren es casi cinco mil
millones de dólares fue el superávit
comercial de brasil en mayo que
significa superávit y que las
importaciones son de 25 mil millones
pero las exportaciones superan ese valor
son de 30 mil millones de dólares y
ambos son un resultado récord el gigante
latinoamericano danny como siempre
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica vamos a pasar a
deportes pero hablar con natalia ruiz y
también con juan pupiales